aux etats unis l'infiltration d'une
taupe du fbi aille dans une mosquée hier
débattu hier la cour suprême des
etats-unis après la plainte de trois
personnes de confession musulmane
oui ils nous accusent ces trois
personnes à la police fédérale de les
avoir mis sous surveillance à cause de
leur religion après les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 voyez les explications de
notre correspondant à washington thomas
monnaie la sphère des buts entre 2006 et
2007 lorsqu'un agent du fbi ya un filtre
une mosquée en californie sa mission
récolter le maximum d'informations sur
les fidèles voire même enregistré des
conversations
et puis la mission va encore plus loin
lorsqu'il tente d'inciter à la violence
en parlant notamment d'attentats à la
bombe et en se montrant insistant en
tenant des propos radicaux sauf que
cette attitude suscite l'inquiétude de
certains fidèles qui décide alors
d'avertir les autorités conséquence cet
argent jette l'épongé et rend publique
son statut d' informateur pour le fbi
dès lors trois fidèles dépose plainte
contre l' agence de renseignement pour
atteinte à la liberté religieuse et
discrimination ils estiment que leur
mosquée a été ciblée sans raison valable
et c'est ainsi que cette affaire
californienne va devenir une affaire
emblématique aux états unis le ministère
de la justice se défend de toute
discrimination en expliquant avoir des
raisons objectives de lancer des
investigations au sein de cette mosquée
mais les autorités se réfugie derrière
le secret d'état afin de ne pas
communiquer ces éléments cela fait donc
des années qu'une bataille juridique se
joue sur cette notion de secret d'état
une procédure résumé par l'avocat de ces
plaignants avec ses interrogations
est-ce que les gens que je représente
vont un jour pouvoir faire valoir leurs
droits les tribunaux sont ils ouverts
pour protéger les libertés religieuses
de cette communauté où le gouvernement
peut-il fermé la porte dès qu'ils
invoquent le fait d'agir pour la
sécurité nationale voilà quelques unes
des questions sur lesquels va devoir se
pencher la cour suprême des etats unis
l'autorité judiciaire américaine qui va
donc devoir statuer sur la recevabilité
des poursuites contre le fbi a et si
c'est le cas alors une audience pourrait
se tenir dans un tribune le fédéral aux
états unis la décision de la cour
suprême sur cette affaire est attendu
pour le mois de juin en 2022